es el tipo de arma que según ucrania
marcará un punto de inflexión en el
campo de batalla en un artículo
publicado en el 'new york times' el
presidente estadounidense joe biden
confirmó la decisión de enviar un nuevo
sistema de cohetes llegó que permitirían
a que atacar con precisión objetivos
clave en el campo de batalla en ucrania
pero añadió que no estaba animando o
permitiendo a ucrania atacar más allá de
sus fronteras los dirigentes de kiev
llevan meses pidiendo este tipo de armas
diciendo que podrían cambiar el rumbo de
la guerra water y kurdo nancy greene
todo el mundo a todos los niveles de
presionar ahora para que se suministre a
nuestro estado armas pesadas modernas y
artillería modernas todos esos sistemas
pueden acelerar realmente la victoria de
ucrania
ok y funcionarios estadounidenses dicen
que el plan es enviar a ucrania un
llamado sistema de cohetes de artillería
de alta movilidad podría dar a las
fuerzas ucranianas la capacidad de
atacar objetivos mientras se mantienen
fuera del alcance de la artillería rusa
y significa que podrían alcanzar
objetivos lejos de las líneas rusas con
mayor precisión el sistema puede
soportar cohetes con un alcance de hasta
300 kilómetros pero los funcionarios
planean suministrar misiles que no
puedan disparar más allá de 80
kilómetros y dicen que ucrania les ha
asegurado que no utilizará las armas
para disparar dentro del territorio ruso
desde que rusia invadió ucrania en
febrero los países de la otan se han
movido en una línea muy fina han
proporcionado apoyo militar a ucrania
pero no han suministrado armamento que
pudiera provocar un enfrentamiento
directo con rusia